[Music]
I'm so glad you're here
I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do
this by myself
your mother is the greatest person let
me tell you how she did it you guys and
you both are so incredible in it the
thing about this movie is like the
inhibition that you have to have and I
feel like the guys are sometimes a
little self-conscious about their
putting on the spandex I knew Josh is a
really good dog yah-yah-yah funny in
that last song when that old just sat at
the bar with a beer and and he's got his
guitar and it took them longer to get
that right then us to do a whole day
yeah so true there they thought they
were getting out of it and then you have
to put them with their younger
counterparts together cute and then
Collins was standing there seriously I
didn't want to dance and so he ended up
winning that argument but that's what
makes it so charming yeah yeah that he's
so awkward about it do you have because
I know you haven't fully embraced the
dancing it's not your favorite thing to
do maybe but do you have a move that you
learned that you now know prior to doing
this film now is this from things I've
said oh because you can just tell no I
love your dancing you are my dancing
queen um no I mean I think fully embrace
just probably taking a little far it
doesn't embrace me entirely I do but
there is something about particular fair
in spandex
what are you doing anything to once
you've built that coach you know so I
you know I I do give myself as fully as
I mean you do come in if this film is
about being uninhibited anyway offend
spandex restricting you're afraid to
tear it aren't you
well no it's so physically it's
restricting but it does there's no point
in I mean you might have a write-off
dignity all three of us are
grandfather's that's that look what
you've done with the place
she wanted to make a mum proud if she
hasn't done that all her life going to
work and having to put the spandex in a
second time as still as humiliating as
it was the first it doesn't get easier
not not particularly it's harder with
you no I think that's going to end up in
a museum so lovely v-neck that your
choice okay no Jake you actually what
cuz I saw this step I think these guys I
saw their costumes no when can we try
something like a bit that was a surprise
yes to old ones Pierce had something a
bit like that and I said oh can I have
one like Pierce yeah because I thought
it'd be nice to fit him with him and and
they grants my wish did you skip because
he was skipping in this valley just give
ya that as far as my dancing talents go
so yeah we had to wait to learn a dance
together at the end and that was that
was quite something getting me and him
here I think I I don't think you mind me
saying this I think you know that the
guys in this movie are significantly
behind the actresses incredible dancing
yeah I know
beautiful singing him we asked whoa
plodding along behind them but that's
the beauty of it that's the beauty of
this film is that you don't necessarily
Bobbie the greatest yeah
the history book commercial is always
repeating inside
I wish defeat to do one
[Music]
between the three of you is the best
answer
yeah don't be Wow happens together like
we say can we become great dancers
remember any move that you guys could do
simultaneously seated we'd like to cover
a lot of ground where we dance distance
to dance I mean my legs my upper body is
very still absolute of Irish in that
sense I'm the guys because they always
seem a little
abashed about the fact that they have to
sing and dance and a little embarrassed
we're women I think are just like well
just like a um who do you think secretly
enjoyed it the most hiss Oh peers first
year peace love love this movie so much
literally bean we would watch like when
we were doing the last bit and all
dancing together we would watch him just
always with a kid he was always just
jumping in love around it he was just
always moving he is a great time you the
party and he's kept he was he was he was
so proud of that
[Music]
if we had seen cuz we see the young
version of Donna and her friends in the
story if we saw the young you and Meryl
because I heard you guys go to it used
to go to the movies together yes what
would tell me like one story or one
thing that we would have seen the two of
you doing together
well unsaid well Meryl Irons I don't
know if she's still hiring and I went
are you crazy
you're Meryl Streep when you're ironing
and I just wanted to take the whole
thing away from her and she said it
keeps me grounded chair it keeps me
grounded well I think she always have
talked about this before is Meryl the
way I see her now of course she is
one of the greatest actors in the
history of the art form if not the
greatest yeah right so for me I think
she also wakes up in the morning as a
mother you know yeah that as an actress
no and you feel that that she's kept it
very separate you didn't want to
impersonate Meryl obviously but you had
some of her gestures and I heard you say
that she talks a lot with her hands and
I love that that's the one thing that I
always noticed about Meryl is that like
every role that you've seen her in her
hands are almost another character so
was there something in particular that
stood out to you like it was her hands
and but the other thing is is that she
just looked like she was so in her body
and so comfortable in her own skin and
so kind of central and right in and her
hips because she was grounded she worked
she was tough you know she was amazing
to watch her though like a gift to be
able to just study Meryl Streep and
study her Donna Sheridan here's the most
magnificent character but were the
mannerisms for each person that used may
be studied or noticed stood out to you
the most I felt really lucky cuz one of
my bad one of my worst habits as an
actress I just use my hands to say
everything but luckily so does Julian
means like I thank God it's something
that I always like I tried to sell my
hand as much as I can but Judy does it
here in that film so that was great but
the voices were the most you know the
tricky a trickiest for me because it's a
sound Judy's got such a distinct voice
and so does Christina Edington manager
we would pull minds from the first film
and before we were when we're setting up
a take and Alexa and I would just toss
them back and forth to each other to
kind of yeah put
like take take take a little bite of it
and yeah I get into character a little
sip just a little soon the Christine
deadpan of stuff legends like that yeah
she's just not seen with her and Julie
where they arrive to the island in this
film and simply goes the two of them
together they can do it silently and
you'd understand I would do it but
that's a pro yeah like like when you
don't feel like you have to like over I
literally take I honestly was like okay
remember that Jessica yeah like that was
like a knife you just did it well yes
because I said I've thought about it
every day you've been doing it for so
long you're so amazing but you still
have those moments always you always
have those every job every day you just
bump into yourself you you get in the
way of yourself you lose your way you
lose your confidence and oh go back to
the beginning of the tags and just pay
attention like a tennis player
yes no let's play you Jesus I've seen
them suddenly fall apart slightly their
game they're they're on their own it was
like us with a camera on us and we
suddenly if you start questioning you or
you can go into kind of a panic mode and
it's right between our years yeah
constantly noobs I've seen some great
actors yeah you know quiver fall apart
and you know everybody you gather around
and supportive each other it happened
actually we did it's always that one
person sometimes and you see and when
you see that happen you just do whatever
you can to get them through to help them
out yeah we all have a little moment of
just what am I doing here standing front
of this camera with this person staring
at me with this thing right here these
lies you so you can just have a
worse on stage you don't get and then
you forget your light the lines I don't
you two with me on my interview so if I
have that moment you can be like yes
yeah we would support it simple keep it
simple breathe and you created the dream
team I mean you started with Meryl with
the last one and then bringing share
onto this one how much of our dream come
true was that well that was a double
dream country yeah Meryl Streep in the
first movie was everything you know to
work with her and she had incredible
ambitions for the movie and then you
know share she's our secret weapon I
mean she was just amazing and but she
was nervous as well you know she she is
a superstar but you know she was there
on a big set with everyone who kind of
knew each other so she was coming in but
now she's very much part of the family
[Music]
[Music]
and there was a fantastic day shooting
where we had Merrill and Pierce Brosnan
and Colin and Julie everyone and the
younger cast and the wonderful Lily
James and it was an exciting few days
and all the cast were kind of standing
on the edge of the soundstage kind of
cheering Shack because it was like they
had their own private concert in Las
Vegas moment yeah and even Meryl was
hiding in the bushes yeah
when does Meryl Streep memorize a city
sitting in a museum jagan camel I have
never felt closer to mom I'm in the
exact same place that she was all those
years ago see my mom so I'm asking
everybody today best advice you ever got
from your mom oh I can I can I say um
can I say suck it in that's so funny
Kip's
thinking about the amount of times that
my mom had to tell me not to chew in my
mouth yeah exactly
my mom said if it doesn't matter in five
years it doesn't matter about that yeah
and his dad said something that your dad
well my dad would always say to never
take a step back we're not even to gain
momentum but my mother would always say
you have what you have your wings fly
[Music]
[Music]
later coming back to any years later do
you feel different do you feel like
everything was sort of you fell back it
was the same as it all was or did you
feel when you stepped on set for the
first time did you feel like a lot of
changed nothing had changed between us
because we you know I haven't been
living together we haven't been even
working together so we just reunited
like as though time we hadn't I mean you
know that wonderful day I was on my way
to the beach with a friend and who's at
the cafe but Stellan talking to all and
while Stella and I were reuniting Pierce
came with his wife hi come and join us
and then you got off the boat that's
right that's right and you had just
arrived and we had this reunion at this
little cafe on a Sunday afternoon we all
ordered coffee or Rose Day or whatever
and we a beer and we just sat there
talking for several hours and it really
it was just if we'd never left yeah so
much affection so much respect between
us and then then we were off and running
doing the film well that comes across on
screen yeah
[Music]
you